[Music]
foreign
so last week a brand new dating app
launched it enters into a crowded
Marketplace already populated by
something like 65 million other dating
apps but it seeks to set itself apart by
specifically targeting conservatives
some people from the Trump Camp
apparently have teamed up with Peter uh
Thiel to bring us what they're What's
called the right stuff which is a
service which says that it was created
for conservatives to connect in
authentic and meaningful ways other
dating apps have gone woke the website
reads but we bring people together with
shared values and similar passions now a
commercial for the app went viral on
social media last week and here it is
check it out
today we brought in a group of
conservative young women and wanted to
get their honest opinions about what
they're looking for in the guys they
date
[Music]
what are you looking for in a partner
they just have to be a conservative
definitely someone that wants to have
kids
I like an independent man personally I
like the alpha male Vibe I want a man
who really loves his family definitely
someone whose faith is important to them
for me it's someone who actually wants
to meet my parents
why do you want a date a conservative
for me at least I know that we're going
to start off with some shared values
while the conservative men I've dated at
least know how to treat me like a woman
in my personal experience conservative
guys have better manners I like that
they understand their role in the
relationship as a man
I just prefer my men to be masculine
and what's the biggest red flag when it
comes to dating a Democrat no Democrats
a Democrat can't be a Democrat a
Democrat that's easy a Democrat no
Democrats to know
find the right match download the right
stuff today
now the acting of the commercial may not
be
award-worthy exactly but then again the
acting in most commercials isn't
award-worthy the main point is the
concept and it's the concept that the
left has been mocking relentlessly
almost all of the reporting on the new
app is focused on how much people hate
it and are making fun of it the
independent reports quote people are
mocking new conservative dating app the
right stuff and the article helpfully
documents some of the lame jokes that
trolls have made about it quote
conservatives are such dorks launching a
dating app called The Right Stuff one
person tweeted while another said the
right stuff dating app sounds like the
stuff nightmares are made of
can't wait to not sign up someone else
joked
these are apparently the best insults
they could find for this article proving
yet again that although leftists may
love to troll which is a passion that I
in fact share with them they are really
not very good at it meanwhile The Daily
Dot reports uh quote some had a hard
time believing that most young women
looking for love would be content with
the type of relationship Dynamic this ad
suggests
quote wait until they're masculine
conservative says when I want your
opinion I'll ask for it or calls you
every day at noon to ask what's for
supper and tells you how his mother did
it another person tweeted one Twitter
user observed that the right stuff is
basically the dating app version of a
safe space for right Wingers
quote let's connect to hey let's connect
to hate immigrants and women's rights
someone else quipped another joke
someone said they're trying to build a
domestic terrorist database
well if I wanted to build a database of
the lamest nerds with the worst insults
I think we could probably we're off to a
good start here although there may
actually be some truth to what the last
guy said I I wouldn't be surprised if
the feds used an app like this to
catfish and entrap conservatives now the
good news though is that you can usually
spot the federal agents based on the
haircut or if he starts suggesting you
know on the first date that you should
try to kidnap the governor or something
then that's you know pretty good
indication
but in any case other leftist outlets
have accused the right stuff of uh of
many other things promoting misogyny
promoting traditional gender roles God
forbid they've blasted it for being
archaic old-fashioned divisive etc etc
they've mocked it belittled it been
offended by it and so on they just
really hate the idea of conservatives
trying to meet each other get married
have babies they really do hate it The
Daily Show with Trevor Noah Noah got in
on the action this week with a painfully
unfunny skit ridiculing the conservative
dating app
on the bright side the bit did extend
Trevor Noah's perfect unbroken streak of
unfunny jokes and he just announced that
he's leaving The Daily Show apparently
soon
um so it looks like he'll retire with a
batting average of 1000 when it comes to
being painfully witless and unfunny so
congratulations to him it is an
impressive accomplishment well in 2020
there were over a thousand significant
online data breaches in the U.S which
left almost 156 million people and their
records exposed that includes sensitive
information related to children now you
wouldn't you wouldn't let your kid walk
home from school without telling them
not to talk to strangers or get into any
windowless Vans but you let them go
online every day without a VPN when
everything they do is tracked for
advertisers and who knows what kind of
creeps could physically track them using
their IP address it's just not sparred
so protect your family's privacy they go
online you've got to use expressvpn
internet service providers know that
every single website you visit they know
all of that isps can sell this
information to add companies and also to
Tech Giants who then use your data to
Target you do you really want all of
these advertisers knowing who's in your
household what your kids like to watch
How to Target them with whatever they're
trying to sell probably not expressvpn
protects your privacy without slowing
your connection no matter how many users
are in your household unlike other vpns
you won't even realize you have it on
it's so easy to use just download the
app on your phone or on your computer
tap one button and you're protected no
one in your family is too old or too
young to figure out how to use it so
secure your family's online activity to
use my link and you can get an extra
three months free expressvpn.com Matt
walshow expressvpn.com Matt Walsh show
but there are a few things here a few
points to make I think
first you have to keep in mind
that the people who make fun of things
like this are almost without exception
single childless and lonely and likely
destined to always remain so
much of what drives so many people in
our society today is the fact that they
are Lonesome and miserable and they want
you to be Lonesome and miserable too
it's one of the universal Timeless Facts
of Life misery loves company why does
Missouri love company well because
miserable people tend to believe that
happiness is kind of graded on a curve
so if they can make everyone else less
happy then their own happiness score
sort of is is raised when compared
against the average
now the math doesn't really work that
way but that won't stop them from
employing that strategy anyway in fact
they will not only try to steer you away
from things that will make you happy but
we'll even try to convince you
that you are unhappy when you aren't
so for example ever since I announced
that we have another set of twins on the
way I have heard from many nasty
comments from trolls insisting that I
cannot actually be happy as a married
man with six kids
the idea of finding contentment and joy
in a life of service to my wife and
children simply doesn't compute with
these shallow flimsy self-centered
little nothings their lives are devoted
entirely to their TVs and their phones
and maybe their pets
so I will grow old with my children and
grandchildren by my side they will grow
old with their Tick Tock accounts and
then they'll die and be forgotten and
leave behind no Legacy
this is the path to fulfillment they
insist
and since my path is the opposite of
what they've chosen they must convince
me that I should be miserable about my
life choices
but that's an impossible uphill battle
because sadly for them
I love my wife and children and can't
imagine a life without them
second point I don't know anything about
this particular dating app aside from
the commercial I don't know if the if
the user base is large enough for it to
actually work I don't know anything
about the app's functionality or lack
thereof when it comes to the execution
it could be a great service it could be
terrible it could be somewhere in
between I'm not really in a position to
test out data gaps so I can't I can't
give you a personal testimony one way or
another but what I can say
is that the idea behind it the idea that
people on the left are deriding
ruthlessly is good
and I want to focus on that on on on the
idea just the idea from
because if you are a mature adult
not looking to waste time not looking
for cheap hookups but rather Desiring a
healthy and committed and serious
relationship most dating apps currently
on the market are a waste of time
because they simply are not designed to
facilitate that sort of thing not
designing for you they're designed for
and mostly used by people who uh want to
use each other for momentary pleasure
and then move on to the next
so it can be difficult to sift through
all of that debris to find actual spouse
material
for that
um you need to find someone who shares
your fundamental values
you don't need to align perfectly on
every last issue you're not looking for
your carbon copy my wife is not a carbon
copy of me I I wouldn't want that I
wouldn't want to marry me I don't know
how she does it frankly but we do share
our core values and beliefs we're
building from the same Foundation
and if you're built from the same
Foundation it's okay to disagree about
some of the furnishings and decorations
and everything which we do in my
marriage you know both the literal and
figurative sense
the other key is that both people in
relationship have to see marriage as the
logical and desired endpoint of dating
dating is is not an end in itself but
rather a vehicle
that takes you somewhere else so you
have to look at it it's a it's a vehicle
um and if both people cannot agree on
the destination or even that there is a
destination you just remain Stuck in
Neutral Forever Until one or both of you
gets bored and bails out of the car
which will likely happen very quickly
and finally
the the man
in the relationship must Embrace his
role as a man and the woman as a woman a
relationship doesn't work if both people
involved don't understand that they
bring something unique and essential to
the arrangement that's what the the the
the much hated and feared gender roles
are really about
it's just about
emphasizing and acknowledging and
highlighting the fact
that as a man you bring something unique
and special to the relationship as a
woman you bring something unique and
special by rejecting sex differences and
gender roles entirely people in romantic
relationships make themselves redundant
and useless with no idea about what
they're supposed to do or why confusion
and paralysis sets in and then the whole
thing breaks down
so
it certainly is the right approach the
right stuff you might say to go into the
dating scene looking for someone who
shares your values who sees marriage as
the end goal of dating and who Embraces
their masculinity as a man or their
femininity as a woman now whether this
particular dating app will successfully
facilitate all that I don't know
but I do know certainly that the leftist
critics in this case are today canceled
if you want to join my exclusive fan
base or a cult as really as that's what
it is or Joy we're forming a cult then
all you do is click the Subscribe button
and ring the bell below uh this video to
stay up to date with all my content and
if you want even more you can watch or
listen to my show at the daily wire.com
Spotify or apple podcast looking forward
to welcoming you to the Sweet Baby gang